Although I'm at Davos, at best in any light
I'm an ordinary person who feels the outrage
that many people do, most people do when they
hear the CEOs receiving huge bonuses, 18.4
billion dollars in bonuses for 2008 performance
or lack of performance. And I think I reflect
the outrage of the ordinary citizen who feels
very strongly about the notion that we were
told that CEOs require those kinds of pay
packages because they are tied to performance.
And then we find out that essentially the
notion of corporate welfare is stronger than
the notion of corporate performance. So I
believe very strongly that the average tax
payer in the U.S. must demand a code of ethics
for corporations that in fact if we are tied
to the notion of paying very, very high figures,
so far outside the understanding of an ordinary
tax payer, ordinary person, wage earner. That
in fact they do tie very strongly to performance
and that they tie to a code of ethic that
in fact reflects the values of ordinary citizens.
Thank you.